have a free one right to the rim
Williams and the jumpers good bye
attacks with jump stop no tap out
rebound by budding earth Minnesota a
chance to the leaves of the three petal
took it down the lane
last night so made the most of his time
on the floor Joelle Anthony
caldwell-pope hasn't blocked my Anthony
Bennett right on cue
what a play Bennett takes the long to
over inheritance and a one possession
game here over Williams on across Darren
Williams doesn't fight another screen
for Bennett Williams Anthony Bennett
just paint he's number one shooting free
throws in the NBA so to me when you're
struggling a little bit simply to the
free-throw line and get a couple of
shots to go down Anthony Bennett which
an exclamatory on the block for Wiggins
good look at Slayer first overall
freshman of the year the big 12 and on
the run it is denied and Wiggins will
save it it's in the sweep
he was a shot break outlet pass by
Anthony Bennett on the leak out Kevin
mark shows enough with Mariah he'll stop
and pop off the front room there were
leaks out in transition
inside the slam dunk for Anthony Bennett
it's a difficult thing if you're a
starting player playing with starters
minutes and having a rookie point guard
front your offense
[Music]
nothing exactly because I thought he did
a pretty good job to question who the
backup center is behind where DJ is
Anthony Bennett and we all can figure
that one out of Hello coming as soon as
you saw that screen happen and you saw
his defense clinic dropping it down
Anthony been shooting the basketball
very well to start this magnus is
finishing up a short to gain road trips
within he'll go home and play brooklyn
tomorrow i love it it gone out weston
they've had some nice wins on the road
so far this season beating the Clippers
beaten the Warriors out on the road beat
the Lakers
[Music]
Collison gets the screen from Derrick
Williams Caspi Anthony Bennett sensit
the other way cousins
Jane loses the basketball numbers for
the walls witness gives it up for
budding her Lori Brewer tries another
three been working the rebound for the
throw down to just about Mohammed this
is what he does pretty well attach the
basket underneath countess foul Anthony
Bennett and will get free throws after
the break the rebound laser-shooting
down to 41 percent against a team that
doesn't play a ton of d and you can see
that's Anthony Bennett there with the
jumper you 90 164 still in the bird now
safe to say we won't see Tim Duncan
again tonight and dropped in by Mohammad
thanks to the floor right now
Minnesota's got an advantage my goodness
poor on to break well I won't say it's a
break before I to in the finish ran
theny petty decision by Zach Lavine to
put the ball in the deck and drive the
seemed Levene's got four assistants on
the night set the other way by Bennett
into the hands of Livingston however
kind of drives to the late best for
engine winds Corey Brewer tries to
gamble to the steel the Tim rules
finally do come up with it look out but
meeting in the open floor last year that
was fourth best in the league the spirit
trade energy defensively as well Spanish
please nice movement a nice finish this
seven to the last eight wolves get a
stop
fewer goes into the hands of Shabazz
pause just non-stop
[Applause]
Bennett lookin for paws on her knee
throws it down that young will bring it
up Anthony Bennett put yeah Robbie
[Applause]
[Music]
good then the Court gives it up the
Bennett straight away J got it Evans
trying to get it inside knocked away by
Bennett Williams feet on the baseline
for the me after the game back
downstairs the days of Jim all right
thank you very much gentlemen
they pay with just his second mate
three-pointer of the season onto the
left corner
Adrian looking down low for Glenn
Robinson it works its way into Anthony
Bennett that is his first dunk in quite
some time
I was tough tonight than the entire the
Waukee Bucks basketball team nine to six
as a matter of math inside the bailiff
did not want anyone else to get this
rebound except Minnesota at the trial
court pad full court it's not a good
decision the long pass bobbled then
picked up this is an obvious statement
but he's going to add some toughness to
this team he's not gonna let him quit
even wearing the Bucks uniform get away
with
[Music]
Pottinger Jiang now sets it with humble
almost not a guy that's going to beat
you off the dribble
second year out of Purdue late a year
overseas here's Bennett jump shot
minutes knocking down and comes up
affected he'll fairly quickly but in the
sense that he's able to play he's
nowhere near that we've seen him do some
some shooting some get it down three
seconds to go Wigan Bennett was it in
time Levine
and here's a nice shot off because it
doesn't go but it's rebounded nicely by
Bennett religion or shot by Daniels on
the 13th while scotland's talked about
that he's gonna get out in transition we
talked about not getting those quick
shots and India in the India half
Wiggins taking it against Courtney Lee
flips it over to Bennet and he be a rim
run in a thrown out
that was a freight train coming down the
lane and nobody wanted to step in front
of it just a little dribble handoff it
may be bad throws it down so hard that
thing back is impressive and that whole
support was shaking
Zach Lavine it's three on the baseline
no ball batted around into the hands of
Bennet nice beat it
Nikola peckish by a B then it screams
gets the bounce back don't go buh-bye
Bennett jams it that looked like a move
to kidding River basket cut mark before
that he was warmed for seven in the
second half would you like better
Bennett underneath program review that
the next stop is to see whether I would
stand mrs. Parikh
[Music]
[Applause]
Jim way players from Asahi jury on this
team Anthony Bennett with great defense
there takes it away from Harris Lowry
pulls up and afraid and they take this
home stand four of six as Bennett
connects among deep which is
under a minute to go here's Bennet on
the drive taking powers
Canadian national teammate the Spurs
play whether to start as a ran to the
subs are in they basically run the same
sets and I think a little bit of that so
far tonight is event picture perfect
evening
Oh baseball basketball defense in the
catalyst kozminski sloppy with a dribble
there Burrell goes out of you
Kilpatrick Bennett inside
and it's an account for the easy dunk
Greivis Vasquez setting up Anthony
Bennett the former Cleveland Cavalier
then it also played with a Raptors knee
from from the free-throw line
opposition student almost 40 more
free-throw attempts than the mixer next
runner over here slam the shatter got
stolen it is back up to 7
[Music]
[Applause]
another Knicks turnover has Ron Baker
get set to check in for the first time
whoa Donovan's from way Matthew two
bonds Harris inside for Anthony pack
miss Li never thought of all coming nine
points throughout the quarter no Quinn
dominating the game with his hustle and
muscle much thinner the baby fat is gone
that's hard to do when you have a great
look from Bennett they're redirecting to
Scola in the corner good Porter Anthony
Bennett teletovic hands up again to let
a [ __ ] learn from Jason Kidd
[Applause]
too deep on the past between two guys he
was grilled cheese and still comes up a
dynamic and it will pull and connect now
two of 12 from three-point range been at
the denial and a turnover
hollis-jefferson
dribbling through traffic bounces
Hamilton waits for two Bennett for three
minutes for Anthony Bennett jump without
the ball and Bennett first hexam's
but there's now by 14 points Bennett
7:3 instead of spending extra duck in
for the scoop we had how the game has
changed
you know guys are expected to shoot that
ball and shoot it from long range and
sometimes you can put guys out there and
give them false confidence to go sit in
those threes that is 18 points now for
Glenn Robinson the third Bennet on a
rack attack chick yogi tonight the
Indianapolis native missed both free
throws had a really good first half and
that's Anthony Bennett just missed two
free throws and now the field goal in
the file said I don't want to count the
years because you know those early 80s
and what-have-you it's just totally
changed strong offensive rebound by
Bennett and then he puts it down he's in
the game couple of blocks hard to even
find a comparison down low all the nice
feed by Harrison what a finish by
Bennett to the Bucks
[Applause]
draws a crowd Kilpatrick open and knocks
it down
hollis-jefferson Nets are shooting 67%
in the field hollis-jefferson on a kick
bennett steps into it hits the frame
nets extend their lead player at
michigan now in his fourth year utah
just didn't have any use for him
bennett back to back yes rattles hold on
a tray quick 53:37 Patrick upstairs to
Bennett T nothing run now for Denver's
bridging the third and fourth quarter
Bogdanovich no
Anthony Bennett like good kick-out to
Bennett who will fire away and hit from
three to call from his agent that the
Spurs were offering a contract in and
out on the second attempt it goes and
it's Bennett on the interior Lopez
almost coughed it up Lin drives in a
crowd looks for the open man catch and
shoot
Bennett knocks it down from long-range
to the floor when he's out there
his vision your spacing he finds dies
Jeremy Lin and and Lowry continues to
just look for pull-up jumper Harris
gives it up
Bennett inside for two they were
expecting a shot I think Harris was
expecting to shoot it as Bennett saves
it shot clock is down to four Bennett's
over see akhom for three then it has an
interesting shot it's not a bad looking
shot the fact of pornstars attractive
and it lays it in as hard as you can get
stuff done it
mentality has to beat development and
getting ready when called upon Bobby's
knocking a pool boy electrons get pulled
in to the game deaf nice shovel Benny
could get another dry does finish and
he's able to do that because of those
warm arms what's up you guys this Taylor
Brooks with bleacher report make sure
that you subscribe for some more video
content